did you hear about gas station
heroin now to gas station heroin oh my
God virie were you right
yep yes he was God damn it score one for
he nailed this one he nailed this one uh
gas station heroin to gas station heroin
you heard me it was being sold at gas
stations but now the US excuse me the
state of attorneys that's horrible what
gas station where Terri what gas station
do we I'm going to launch an
investigation immediately is this as
prevalent as like Delta 8 at gas
stations I don't I mean I'm so mad that
like they do [__] like this all the time
and then I never know about it like I
used to
be closer to the yeah closer to the stre
be more tapped in yeah and it hurts my
feelings now that become such an out of
touch old man that hangs out with his
cats all day and I never know when that
gas station's got heroin for for sale I
probably would have bought Zaza is that
what that is with Zaza is that what that
is Virgie what is this I'm not kidding I
absolutely would have bought [__] gas
station heroin I think it's something
along the lines of like crom but not
okay it's it's like a research chemical
katum got it oh so it's not even really
heroin then o yeah it's the same kind of
[__] alkaloid act it's heroin spice
good yeah that's great it's heroin spice
it's heroin spice which honestly it's so
sad she left the band but she was sick
she needed to get well see man Spice
Girls was an all girls band from like
the 9s mhm you know if you want to be my
love oh I've heard that song good they
invented polyamory that's true they did
I thought the Mormons did
that
okay she's caught up that far good she's
read up to that she at least read the
book of Mormon she's definitely read
that you seen the musical oh then you've
nailed it that's all you need to know
she she's like right now I'm on slavery
in the Civil War Don't Tell Me How It
Ends don't spoil it for me I don't want
to know personally rooting fur the South
but that's just between you right up to
1864 and I got a feeling next year is
going to be real
great taken off the shows and done so
immediately Connor Hansen is here
tonight Connor oh God poor Connor Hansen
again this is the guy that's con H here
with another great assignment they
giving him the he did something this guy
did something to them
Fu was doing like a story about like
what was it like [__] cats or
something stupid and now today they have
him doing the gas station heroin I think
they hate this reporter yeah yeah Conor
Hansen here live from Pine Hills again
because I think they're just trying to
get me killed this is great I think it's
scary that he's bigger than the lady
yeah well look look local news really
needs to stand out now when old people
are CH changing channels it really has
to pop like an episode of Jag it does it
does look like speaking to like her
villain boss right like have you
obtained the diamond yet or the micro
fish you're like not yet sir there Power
Rangers reboot is [__] lit and where
is Bucky Barnes what what's
happening is this
stuff mariss it's branded as a sort of
anti-depressant but it's something you
could buy at a gas station convenience
store even online where where you're not
helping me help me out want to do heroin
we want to do
drugs also he acts like that's a false
description [__] when I did heroin it
made me happy mhm exactly for it does
make you happy for most of the time yep
now it's illegal to buy or it doesn't
the drug here in Florida and some other
states now now it's illegal so he's
right it's a research chemical perfect
capsules of the tianeptine are sold as a
dietary supplement which means don't
worries Bros cuz this is going to be
another one in like two weeks we're
going to what we talked about the first
hour they're going to change the
molecule that's it sometimes called
Pegasus Tiana or Zaza red drugs have
shitty names now yeah they really do can
we talk about how shitty they're called
now it's the Zoomer culture they suck
what happened just acid and that's it we
knew what it was $34.99 let's see what
we get for zazar red what do we get for
some Zaza red what are you going to do
what we not going to up here it's
different from opioids but can some of
the same effects and officials say it's
harmful addictive and unregulated
officials say it's harmful that must be
true and it must be good is this the
only brand that it's under I I guarantee
you that there's other brands but I
think Zaza is the one I've heard in like
rap songs ah there's also there's also
black mamba and K that's Kobe
rip Florida's Poison Control Center had
15 exposure calls in the first half of
this year did anybody die though that's
what I want to know year the Attorney
General's office says the drug has
killed five people AC okay well it's
five people ratio to how many took it
though across the country an addiction
across the
country five people across the country
five people across the country is a
little ridiculous that's like one death
per 10 states yeah this is fine us
people might honestly now that people
are dying from it now more people are
going to want it that's what always
happens with these things you guys
Market this now now everyone wants Zaza
I'm literally that's all why I got
distracted I've Mer's looking for Zaza I
want some does someone have a Zaza plug
are there any are there any like black
people in the audience where can I get a
Zaza or really just real perks can we
get those back what happened to those
now you just ask for [__] straight up
drugs they just made this illegal this
is drugs sort of try to use the gas
station heroin to mimic the real thing
you're going to end up doing more of
this and by the way V told me all
heroins gas station heroin if you're
desperate enough for a stall yeah true
or sometimes when you're buying it where
else you going to meet the guy yeah good
point you know a
KFC he works at very specific vgy
rallies rallies you guys call it
Checkers
Checkers this to where do you buy your
heroin chat to get that same feeling and
unfortunately by the time you take
enough of is to get that feeling you may
accidentally harm yourself cuz you don't
know what else is in
it Conor I know this is an emergency
rule but could this become but could you
bring me some yeah oh it's emergency
rule it's not a law yet huh no but it's
an emergency rule so you better [__]
have an Emer well I don't follow unjust
emergency rules that's right that's
right sixer Tannis m is only MCH is only
andap when it comes to drugs mhm and I'm
very andap when it comes to drugs
a permanent
ban honestly the worst drug I've ever
done in my life that made me feel the
word more than anything else was when I
smoked spice that stuff made me feel
like I wanted to die I've had I've had
I've been warned about spice once and
then I was like you know I've never had
the opportunity to take it so I don't
know what it's like it's not worth it
just do regular drugs okay it's because
you don't know what you're it really is
like with that stuff like you don't know
what you're getting you know and it'll
[__] you up like I was getting heart
palps like it was really bad yeah I only
smoked spice like once like when I was
down in South Florida and I hated it and
then another time I accidentally smoked
spice and it gave me a [__] asthma
which does happen cuz somebody will hand
you a blunt and you never you know
normally this bow you think it's weed or
what or a bowl too you think it's weed
and then it turns out to be spice and
then you're [__] one of the one of the
dancers that worked at the club I was at
in New York I uh I was the opening
manager that day so like there was
pretty much only five people in the
building and it was Daylight it's not
what you think he worked at the ballet
yeah the ballet it was a
juliard um no but I uh so I go in there
one of the dancers that came plenty of
those [__] were trying to fund their
art school though I I used to tell these
[__] if you get here earlier on time
I'll give you a free drink and I'll let
you smoke some weed in the dressing room
before you get ready so that like I have
girls in the building and I'd be cool
about it so one chick was packing a bowl
and I was like going in the dressing
room and I'm like what up girl am I
going to hit that she's like oh yeah
she's handed to me does not tell me it's
spice why would you why it sounds like
spice [__] I flipped out on that [__] I
was like don't ever hand I thought it
was weed don't ever hand me some [__]
that ain't just weed does it last as
long as we longer at least for me I look
I'll tell you for me for me it felt like
it it La it lasted uh way longer because
I don't know what it is man I felt
terrible I remember feeling this is many
years ago by the way but here's thing
about spice mint uh it used to just be
this research chemical
jw18 or one or some [__] right and then
they banned that and so instead of
shipping over [__] that had jwh on it
they just decided hey we're just going
to try all our research chemicals out so
they just started spraying it with
synthetic cannaboids oh and so you could
buy one off the shelf and then buy the
next one on the same shelf and it' be
two completely different chemicals that
you have no idea so you really don't
know what you're getting so like it's
not like you could gauge like look with
weed I know there's different strangers
and that but for the most part I know
what weed
there is a baseline experience I know
what going to feel like or any other
drug I kind of know what mushroom's
going to feel like I get it but with
this stuff it's like it's a roll of the
dice you'll get really sleepy really
[__] height like you have no idea
it's not worth or you could just
hallucinate you could end up smoking a
disassociative and getting in like a
khole and [__] super fun I love drugs
and I I love all sorts of drugs but I
don't like drugs that I cannot plan
around yeah I have to plan around
whatever drug I'm doing if we're doing
mushrooms great plan a day we'll pick a
nice
go somewhere it's nice fresh air be like
it's beautiful you go to a park in the
fall like this is beautiful uh if I'm
doing [__] you know like if I get a
couple perks or whatever like I don't do
those anymore I had some be like today's
a video game day today I'm getting some
dominoes I'm just going to St in my
gaming chair and take these two perks
I'm just going to play Starfield all day
and chill there's certain things I need
to plan around I don't like if I'm
planning on [__] there's a certain
drug I want to you know if it's just
vagra well yeah nowadays oh it sounds
like a gambler's drugs people like
every yeah every research chemical I
have ever done has been a [__] awful
experience so it's like gambling but
every [__] uh every [__] number on
the board is a different flavor of [__]
sandwich